tvw dinge präsentiert von der leyen für
alle wohl enger und weniger lang weg
sind
[Musik]
auf der suche nach dem glück nimmt der
mensch weite wege auf sich
den himmel auf erden vermuten wir meist
dort wo wir nicht sind in der ferne
jahr für jahr wandern tausende
schweizerinnen und schweizer aus und
beginnen im ausland ein neues leben
wir haben auswanderer begleitet vor
einem jahr suchten sehr glück in costa
rica in australien und auf kreta marcel
breuer und seine frau beatrice
verkauften kurz entschlossen ihr haus im
kanton solothurn
sie wollten raus aus dem alltagstrott
und wanderte nach griechenland aus
[Musik]
auf kreta eröffneten sie eine rock und
blues bar eine nervenaufreibende zeit
[Musik]
familie landolt aus glarus übernahme in
australien ein ferien resort und wollte
dort mit den aborigines zusammenarbeiten
[Musik]
doch die finanzierung der anlage stellte
die familie vor große schwierigkeiten
[Musik]
das happy end schien in greifbarer nähe
aber alles kam anders wir haben nun
keine legale basis mehr für unseren
antrag der vertrag ist abgelaufen
verkäufer bild verlor die geduld er
klagte vor gericht und familie landolt
musste freie krieg verlassen ist ein
flexibler machen
[Musik]
perfekte wellen das ganze jahr hindurch
in santa teresa an der westküste costa
rica skaten mike wittner und nicole
gerstner den sprung in ein neues leben
zusammen mit ihren drei kindern
samstagnachmittag um diese zeit hätte
sich mike vor zwei jahren noch um die
kunden in seinem laden in thun kümmern
müssen und snowboards verkauft hat er
viel mehr zeit für seine familie den
skaterpark neue attraktion in santa
teresa die familie wollte der hektik des
schweizer alltags entfliehen
aber die alte heimat ganz aufgegeben
haben sie nicht
und bequemer 42 wie schwierig der staat
in costa rica sein würde hätten sie auf
den ersten blick nicht vermutet schauen
wir mit der familie noch einmal zurück
auf eine zeit als sie das gute alte
leben hinter sich ließen
anderthalb jahre haben sie auf diesen
tag hingearbeitet
doch der letzte schritt zu ihrem großen
traum
fällt ihnen schwerer als gedacht
sich von den freunden verabschieden ist
für nicole besonders schwierig
[Musik]
die freunde sind ihre familie denn ihre
eltern sind bereits verstorben
[Musik]
aber welche bewusst du sondern markt
buch gehört irgendwie mit der
vergangenheit abschließen sich unter
nagasato nach unterschrift zukunft dass
ich vor einer reaktion auf vortags
geworden
auswandern und sich gleich alleine
durchschlagen müssen so hat sich nicole
das familienabenteuer nicht vorgestellt
georgen und seiner schwester fährt sie
nach santa teresa voraus micron show
mussten in der hauptstadt san josé
bleiben mike wartet auf einen
geländewagen den er von der schweiz aus
gekauft hat und der noch nicht fertig
ist
für die ersten monate haben die
auswanderer zwei häuschen gemietet
sie haben sie im internet gefunden jetzt
da nicole die unterkunft zum ersten mal
in realität sieht macht sich ja nicht
darum breit
[Musik]
das ist momentan nicht angeschlossen was
nicole vorher auch nicht wusste die
bungalows liegen außerhalb des dorfes
mitten im dschungel
es gibt nur ein kleines problem ich kann
den schlüssel nicht aber morgen bringe
ich mit dem licht das licht mache ich
später
[Musik]
bruder wieder das volle leben die
flotten sprüche des verwalters können
nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen dass die
beiden häuser nicht eben paradiesisch
sind
[Musik]
nach zehn jahren immer so im tumorbett
sitzung zur kriegsvorbereitung
nach fünf wochen im provisorium ist es
endlich soweit mike und nicole sind
unterwegs zu ihrem neuen zuhause
die villa mit pool haben sie vor wenigen
tagen gekauft
[Musik]
nun scheint die familie endlich im
tropenparadies angekommen zu sein
[Musik]
auch strom abnehmen mit einem wellness
trip pro jahr noch geheim
die zahlen jetzt 40 die hände gerät ist
ich glaube es ist gut
[Musik]
an der herr moser valley school beginnt
das neue schuljahr erster schultag für
kroatien und shoah und für die kleine
josephine einschulung die neuen
mitschüler kommen aus der ganzen welt
und die lehrer spreche nur spanisch oder
englisch
tochter rosalie gegen in thun noch in
den kindergarten
dort war sie bestens integriert und
hatte jede menge freunde
in costa rica wird charlene eingeschult
sie kennt niemanden und versteht kaum
ein wort
sie hofft dass sie den tag gut
überstehen
dazu fuhr kinderleicht denn es versteht
sich dass sommerausgabe trend könnte
über tauschen und wer bekommt dadurch
eine frau drin
mike und nicole machen sich an die
arbeit sie wollen auf ihren neuen
grundstück vielen häuser bauen
zusätzlich zu ihrer wähler haben die
beiden noch 5000 quadratmeter land
gekauft
auf diesem terrain hätten locker zwei
bungalows platz wie viele bungalows es
werden sollen darüber sind sich die
beiden noch nicht einig klar ist aber
womit sie ihr projekt beginnen wollen
mit einem kleinen haus das versteckt
unter palmen auf ihrem grundstück liegt
[Musik]
ihr problem das haus ist noch bewohnt
eine familie aus nicaragua wohnt hier
carla mit zwei kindern und ihrem mann
kam helau
er war beim vorbesitzer hausmeister
[Musik]
die hausmeister familie hat kein festes
einkommen mehr
jetzt wo nicole und mike die villa
gekauft haben er hat sich nicht
definitiv nicht
die schweiz auf mit der kündigung und
holsteins zustimmung sollte sich nach
rang und lag um sie ganz klar aus mit
situationen genau die gleiche krankheit
ist nicht nur ein gutes jahr lang haben
wir vielleicht die ausstellung kann vom
normalen hintersinnig schaffen und so
weiter und so fort
eigentlich
[Musik]
carmelo durfte sich auf dem grundstück
von mike und nicole eine neue bleibe
bauen für sich carla und die kinder
mike hat ihnen das baumaterial bezahlt
die schweizer fühlen sich für die kleine
familie verantwortlich und mit carlos
hilfe bessert mike sein spanisch auf wo
carmelo bisher wohnte steht kein stein
mehr auf dem anderen
[Musik]
unter aufsicht von architekt gar die
soll ein stilvolles gästehaus entstehen
als gelernter zimmermann wollte mike
selber hand anlegen
doch dieser plan ging nicht auf
nach der spanisch richtige material am
richtigen ort zu bekommen und macht und
das ist frau medica touren mit diesen
jungs und ich auch nur sagen
einfach nur zuschauen ist für mike immer
noch ungewohnt
[Musik]
auch die kleine josephine kommt nicht
richtig an ihn aus der liga sie hat
heimweh und vermisst die schweiz zur
ablenkung darf die sechsjährige zum
reitkurs zusammen mit ihrem bruder
george michael hofft dass tochter
josephine beim reiten ihr heimweh
vergisst und eine freundin findet es
schlimm und es geschah aber trotz aller
schwierigkeiten gut gelaufen und war ich
nie wie viel geld man sitzt du weißt ja
nicht wie es für die sauber ich hoffe er
ist
betritt man das ist einfach geworden
aber man sagt auch schon gefragt mein
gesunder friede freude eierkuchen
krieger und korn nicht wie ich das
geschafft ist der erste ferienbungalow
fertig er hat zwei schlafzimmer und
platz für fünf personen
mike hat extra nach tischchen
geschreinert das paar hat sein erstes
etappenziel erreicht die vermietung des
ferien bungalows inzwischen prächtig
angelaufen und sohn joshua ist 15
geworden
die familie muss sich bald entscheiden
ob er eine berufslehre macht ein grund
in die schweiz zurückzukehren
[Musik]
auch marcel und seine frau beatrice
wollten ihren traum leben
sie eröffneten die eigene rock und blues
bar in der schweiz kündigten sie ihre
sicheren jobs und wanderte nach
griechenland aus aber so schön hätte
sich das paar ihr neues leben nie
vorgestellt seit anfang 2015 wohnen sie
in dieser wille
[Musik]
so
die villa liegt nicht nur näher an der
bar als die vorherige wohnung sie ist
auch noch günstig rund 1300 euro kostet
sie im monat
drinnen macht ihr frau tricks vezzali
der süßgebäck ist der renner bei mars
gästen machen
der pico vorbereiten und aber das habe
ich momentan lang zeit zum vorbereiten
[Musik]
schick
mit fleiß und durchhaltevermögen haben
marcel und tricks ihr glück gefunden
ein neues haus ein traumhafter ausblick
und direkt am hafen von aion nicola die
eigene bar
hallo die gastfreundschaft haben marcel
und tricks im blut aber miteinander
hatten sie es zu beginn ihrer
auswanderung nicht immer einfach
buholzer und seiner frau tricks beginnt
im dunkeln im dorf er länder beziehen
sie eine wohnung
sie haben diese unterkunft während ihres
letzten aufenthalts in kreta gemietet
eine spedition hat bereits den gesamten
haushalt der buchholzer cindy neue
wohnung gebracht rund 1000 euro pro
monat bezahlen sie für die vier zimmer
tricks wusste genau wie sie ihr nest in
griechenland einrichten möchte einige
dieser möbel hat sie extra noch in der
schweiz gekauft
offiziell liegen oder sitzen würde
es gab für 82 schloss ist ja mal waren
wir natürlich offen
also gestritten aber die cholera minimal
und beendete es noch einen moment jetzt
also wieder das wort sondern die haben
sehr große schwierigkeiten immer noch
nicht wofür es ist vor saison seit sechs
wochen wohnt marcel buchholz mit seiner
frau auf kreta freunde haben die
solothurner noch keine gefunden dafür
aber ein lokal
seit eineinhalb jahren ist es
geschlossen ich war vieles machen aber
den mann ist eben nach region aufgrund
aber da muss man eine neue karriere
die schrift ruf des aquarius und du sich
natürlich schon morgen sondern sich ganz
schön
liga
[Applaus]
schon am nächsten tag ist es soweit
masse stellt die weichen für ihr neues
leben mit dem geld geht's zum anwalt
dort unterzeichnen marcel und tricks den
pachtvertrag der anwalt erwartet das
ehepaar bereits im büro in seinem
wohnhaus tricks wird herzlich von ella
der maklerin begrüßt sie hat die bar
vermittelt
es soll aus das geld bekommt der
vorbesitzer der bar als ablöse für das
inventar müssen sie 40.000 euro bezahlen
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das sind die bahn er übernimmt das ist
aber verdacht vorgestellt und dort sechs
aktuellen zeitpunkt ist einfach denn
durch sie wird die paarung sich als
richtige 7 ist gemacht
[Musik]
ein neuer lebensabschnitt beginnt marcel
ist nun stolzer besitzer einer bar
jonas
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in sechs wochen möchte marcel erste
gäste bewirten
bis dahin haben er und ehefrau tricks
die aufgaben klar verteilt noch wie mein
vordermann bringen und das machen wir
mussten ganz allein schafft marcel den
umbau aber doch nicht er hat bei nico
eingestellt der grieche hat früher hier
hinter dem tresen gearbeitet
[Musik]
alles okay das letzte bier wurde in
diesem lokal vor eineinhalb jahren
gezapft seitdem hat sich manch
unliebsame bewohner ein gelistet und
sechs wochen klären haben das ist
wirtschaftlich wort genommen
marcel hat einen anstrengenden
arbeitstag in der bar hinter sich doch
zu hause ist für ihn noch nicht
feierabend tricks hat vorher besorgt mit
denen sie den balkon verschönern möchte
überhaupt ist entweder es anders kommen
das ist gut rausgekommen ist das nicht
versteht sie auch es probleme mit der
kripo hat oder was wir wirklich das war
gut und das nächste sonderlob das kreuz
sowie es einfach dazu mit 15 jahren
marcel werner rock und blues bar
alles ist bereit fast alles
[Musik]
doch ich will den verein stufe gegen für
das boxen
das ist eigentlich kein echter bonus und
da ist sie ja und ich habe als derzeit
auf models trugen ein gedicht das war ja
endlich kommt der techniker mit dem
verstärker gerade noch rechtzeitig
[Musik]
wir haben lange auf mich gewartet haben
muss ich ja schon
[Applaus]
die eröffnungsparty ist in vollem gang
rund 100 gäste sind ins der sap gekommen
freunde aus der schweiz handwerker
nachbarn aber auch einige touristen
[Musik]
als gastgeber und chef der messe
natürlich eine rede halten
auf griechisch maklerin l hat sie
übersetzt
dalos
doch braucht
klein ist
[Musik]
komm schon du weißt doch wie es geht
hallo zusammen ich versuche es auf
griechisch und nicht zuletzt vielen dank
auch an tricks meine wunderbare frau für
ihr verständnis und die geduld besonders
in den letzten sechs wochen
ich liebe dich marcel und seine gäste
haben eine lange nacht vor sich das
ergebnis wurde natürlich dass ich ganz
gerade wäre gestorben
man muss man darum programm hat eine
tolle story bartoli umsichtigen also für
mich stimmt so hundertprozentig muss ich
sagen lieber am hafen für marcel ist ein
herzenswunsch in erfüllung gegangen und
die beziehung hat gehalten
tricks startet nun ihr eigenes geschäft
aber dazu später
[Musik]
das ferienhaus am strand ist nur eine
übergangslösung gemietet haben es miriam
landolt und ihre familie im juli 2015
mussten landes die ferienanlage freie
krieg per gerichtsbeschluss verlassen
sie konnten den vereinbarten kaufpreis
nicht aufbringen
dabei hatte alles so gut angefangen der
gästebetrieb lief unter miriams führung
immer besser
doch der traum vom leben und arbeiten
mit den aborigines ist jäh geplatzt
aufgeben wollen sie dennoch nicht dass
ich keine option ziehen
miriam und ihr mann seal wollen
weitermachen bis es soweit ist hat
miriam den familienalltag in australien
so gut es geht am laufen
sie hoffen dass sie ihre träume im
zweiten anlauf umsetzen können
für jannis und seine geschwister ist
coffs harbour bereits zur heimat
geworden
diesmal stehen die lunchbox das gibt dem
heißen blechdach kontrollieren
miriam echte abstand zur freude krieg
gewinnen im ferienhaus am strand plant
sie die nächsten schritte
auf der anderen seite der erdkugel ist
ehemann seal unterwegs zum flughafen
zürich er lebt und arbeitet nach wie vor
in der schweiz seine familie in
australien sieht er nur alle paar monate
wissen wir
aber ich weiß dass es dass das konzept
und das erfolgt deshalb funktioniert
schaut dass man keiner kaufen
der traum vom eigenen ferien resort und
der zusammenarbeit mit den ureinwohnern
hat vor mehr als zwei jahren begonnen
juni 2013
das neue zuhause von familie landolt
liegt an der regenreichen ostküste
australiens nur wenige autominuten von
coffs harbour entfernt schön ist allein
mit den vier kindern voraus gerecht
das gelände ist 40 hektar großen ferien
bungalows stehen darauf und das wohnhaus
der familie
kostenpunkt 2,4 millionen franken
das ist mehr als die planer besitzen und
die finanzierung ist noch nicht geregelt
als frau will hier ihre vision vom leben
und arbeiten mit den ureinwohnern
verwirklichen
insbesondere kuba wirklich drauf soll
die neuankömmlinge schützen eine alte
zeremonie der aborigines jerry kelly ist
stammesoberhaupt für die familie landolt
ist er ein guter freund aber auch ein
geschäftspartner sind hier leider ohne
dass mir vorhin auch begleitete sind mit
den ureinwohnern wollen landeskultur
programme anbieten
in der schweiz geht derweil das leben
für ihre frau miriam seinen gewohnten
gang
sie wäre gerne bei ihrer familie aber
als schulleiterin ist sie noch sechs
wochen an ihren arbeitsvertrag gebunden
die auswanderung fordert für sie gleich
zu beginn ein großes opfer wo kinder
sind
im ferien resort friday krieg macht sich
ehemann schön an die arbeit die neue
ferienhäuser hat eine freundin der
familie vorübergehend verwaltet
janet blaney zeigt wie sie die häuser
für gäste vorbereitet in zukunft macht
das familie landolt ich bin in einem bei
ferienhäusern gleich bei ihnen das war
eine junge frau die hier auf dem gelände
heiraten möchte wir werden sie nun
treffen ihre fragen beantworten und wir
die anlage zeigen damit sie sich ein
bild davon machen kann
schön überlässt es janet die besucherin
übers gelände zu führen
er sieht sich eher als mann im
hintergrund der sich um die finanzen
kümmern
die rolle der gastgeberin ist für frau
miriam vorgesehen sobald sie hier ist am
abend telefonierte mit dem verkäufer der
liegenschaft 2,4 millionen franken
müssen landolt aufbringen
ein großer teil davon fehlt immer noch
und die zahlungsfrist läuft bald ab
es sieht gut aus
sogar sehr gut wir tun unser bestes um
den termin für die zahlung zu halten
sie wäre es besser wenn wir so schnell
wie möglich bezahlen
das wissen wir sie setzt darauf
investoren in der schweiz zu finden als
finanzspezialist hat er ein gutes
netzwerk aber bis jetzt hat er nur vage
zu sein
doch plötzlich gar lustig wie zum
finanzierer und das ist ganz wichtiger
schritt für die aus draußen ist oder wie
man nachts für die fahrt ist abermals
und der fertigung bis über acht prozent
frauen das ist eine völlig abstrus
[Musik]
zwei wochen später heißt es abschied
nehmen
[Musik]
vater schön muss zurück nach glarus er
verlässt seine kinder noch bevor mutter
miriam hier eintrifft seinen job
behalten
der traum vom auswandern bedeutet für
ihn über 10.000 kilometer pendeln gibt
es auch finanzielle sicherheit beliebte
pflichten moment weniger stress für mich
außer mir jetzt völlig des 2
bis mutter miriam endlich kommt schaut
janet nach den kindern
wiedersehensfreude bei tochter miriam
ihre mutter ist in coffs harbour
angekommen
[Musik]
miriam kann nun endlich wieder für ihre
kinder da sein aber es wartet auch viel
arbeit auf sie im ferien resort
[Musik]
am anderen ende der welt stürzt sich
vater schön in die arbeit
er ist finanzchef in der schweiz bei
einem international tätigen unternehmen
und mit der familie und will auch für
und flamme für das projekt finden die
wenn es traurig dann irgendwie doch
nicht auto zu holen und somit auch die
entenfamilie stelle die finanzierung des
ferienresorts ist ein ungelöstes problem
um das sich schild dringend kümmern muss
auf friday krieg hat sich eine
hochzeitsgesellschaft mit 80 gästen
eingemietet wir dekorieren noch fertig
und dann brechen wir wahrscheinlich auf
um vier kommen wir wieder
bis dahin bin ich zurück dann machen wir
eine probe melde dich wenn du etwas
brauchst ab sofort ist miriam
hotelmanagerin zimmermädchen und
hausmeisterin in einem
nur eine putzfrau und ein gärtner helfen
ihr miriam und ihre familie sind
dringend auf einnahmen angewiesen
solange das ressort nicht vollständig
bezahlt ist haben sie es nur gepachtet
monat für monat müssen sie rund 12000
franken aufbringen für bis zu 280
franken welche gäste pro nacht bezahlen
und sie ein zimmer ohne ungeziefer und
tatsächlich miriam hat eine spinne
entdeckt
in glarus schleppte man schön die
letzten persönlichen gegenstände aus dem
ehemaligen wohnhaus der familie um geld
zu sparen wollen lang dolls es vermieten
bereits zweimal stand schön mit
australischen banken kurz vor dem
abschluss aber diesen war das projekt zu
unsicher
sie haben auf seinen job in der schweiz
nicht als sicherheit akzeptiert
[Musik]
zur situation zieht das sie dauert die
unterstützung leichter um moderne
braucht sich auch nicht bei 7.040 und
waldrand von der familie
das macht einen natürlich schon wieder
lachen wie das nicht sagen aber in der
frage ausgangsmodell einfach zu finden
[Musik]
so kommt bis auf weiteres bei freunden
unter
[Musik]
exotische klänge auf freie krieg miriam
landolt hat für schweizer gäste ein
kulturelles programm organisiert das
welcome to country ist eine
traditionelle zeremonie der aborigines
das programm für gäste hat miriam
gemeinsam mit den ureinwohnern
entwickelt wird und sicherlich so dass
man möglichst viel geld die programme
und das virtuose das ist damit nicht in
sicht
die ferienanlage läuft unter miriams
führung immer besser
lichtblicke gibt es auch bei den
finanzen
ein australischer investor interessiert
sich für schönes neues konzept
zusätzlich zum ferien resort möchte
schön landwirtschaft betreiben
aborigines anstellen und teebaumöl
produzieren londons läuft aber die zeit
davon in einer stunde kommt verkäufer
bild vorbei er will endlich sein geld
der jüngste der familie hat bereits sein
sparschwein geplündert
[Musik]
von jannis für freie krieg trotz neuem
konzept und dem interessierten investor
möchte verkäufer will keinen aufschub
mehr gewähren
im letzten jahr zeit läuft und hat dann
lässt man den gekloppt oder und sind im
blickpunkt ein bisschen wieder da und
damals setzte adidas airbus oder jetzt
einfach nicht der 30 und miriam sind
sich aber sicher dass es dieses mal
klappt mit dem partner sind habe ich
auch nicht dass baukosten hypothek
spricht die station und er bekommt und
dann hast du plötzlich macht sie so ganz
viele mögliche andere gruppen
alles hängt davon ab ob sie es schaffen
verkäufer bild von ihrem konzept das
geld bringen soll
zu überzeugen sie haben den vertrag
gekündigt ist abgelaufen
nehmen wir an ich verlängere dann
vertragen um 14 tage
und diese investoren geben ihnen
trotzdem nicht das geld was wird dann am
15 geschehen
wir sind ganz sicher dass wir die
risikoprüfung des australischen
investoren bestehen innerhalb der frist
bis zum 15
ja bis dahin werden sie etwas in der
hand haben sie sind sehr optimistisch
million
sie haben in den letzten zwei jahren
nichts zustande gekommen das ist ihre
perspektive wir haben bisher alle unsere
ziele erreicht das einzige was nicht
funktionierte ist der kreditvertrag weil
die bank kurz vor abschluss ihre zusage
zurück
sie müssen doch zugeben dass ihre
und weise wie sie geldgeber für das
resort suchen sehr ungewöhnlich ist
niemand macht das so ich verstehe ihre
zweifel aber wir haben eine größere
vision hast nur dieses resort zu
betreiben wir wollen mit den
ureinwohnern zusammen arbeiten und dafür
braucht es unorthodoxe wege und wir
haben nun einen solchen gefunden
das ist jetzt der beste weg und die
beste möglichkeit fakt ist sie hätten
bereits am ersten oktober ausziehen
müssen
wir geben ihnen noch einmal zwei wochen
einen weiteren aufschub werden wir ihnen
auf keinen fall mehr gewähren
dessen müssen sie sich bewusst sein
ok bei
[Musik]
zwei wochen später auf friday krieg ist
die zeit für landolf abgelaufen
heute ist der tag an dem sie ihre sachen
packen müssten und die zusage des
investors steht immer noch aus aber die
familie hält an ihrem traum fest dann
unvermittelt eine nachricht auf miriams
mobiltelefon landes haben die
risikoprüfung tatsächlich bestanden
die familie bekommt das geld vom
australischen investor die finanzierung
von freitag weg schien gesichert
doch die geschichte von familie landolt
nahm eine andere wendung
während grundsätzliche finanzielles
risiko wir haben aber zu dem zeitpunkt
konditionen bedingungen im detail kaum
die haben wir dann später über co die
haben wir dann studiert war ausgerollt
und prüft und fast nie ist eine mittel
bis langfristige finanzierung sie und
nennt man so sagen das ist es das
konzept wurde nämlich auf stufe und dann
habe ich mir gesagt hat ein aus
wirtschaftlichen gründen kam etwas
bewegung mit effekten diego das ist kein
einfacher weg sie hätten sie aber was
nützt es auch nicht dass die menschen
von könne man aber mit der familie
das haben die welle machen
[Musik]
trotz aller bemühungen konnte will keine
investoren mehr finden und bill wollte
sich auf einen weiteren pachtvertrag
nicht einlassen
er klagte beim obersten gericht von new
south wales auf rückgabe des
grundstückes kurz vor dem gerichtstermin
einigten sich beide parteien auf einen
vergleich der landes weitere zwei monate
zur zahlung einräumte
als die familie auch diesen termin nicht
einhalten konnte kam der fall vor den
richter
[Musik]
meinungsverschiedenheiten wenn das
größte interessenkonflikt mit dem auto
aber ich denke das gehört zur natur vom
geschafft dass man immer gleicher
meinung ist die handcremes für ist auch
ihre kraft fürs rechte die hand steht
für sichere kautions für die ganze hand
investitionen soll die infrastruktur mit
das ganz marketing punkte sind immer
mehr zahlt als eingangspforte zum garant
uwe und michael dass der süße
abgerechnet wird
das gericht bestätigte den vergleich das
eigentum des anwesens ging an verkäufer
bild zurück familie landolt musste freie
krieg im juli 2015 verlassen
danach stellten beide parteien
gegenseitige forderungen mittlerweile
konnten sie sich aber außergerichtlich
einigen
[Musik]
während der mittagszeit ist es ruhig in
der bar bei frühsommerlichen
temperaturen tummeln sich die touristen
am strand maße nutzt die freizeit für
einen einkauf
im britischen supermarkt ist der
stammkunde
[Musik]
es sind zwei packungen guinness falls
diese nicht reichen sollten hole ich
morgen noch einmal 2 marcel fühlt sich
in griechenland pudelwohl
sein alter job als vertreter ist für ihn
abgehakt
selbständig zu werden mehr oder weniger
macht für mutter
als chef seiner bar genießt er die neue
freiheit in vollen zügen
[Musik]
auch ev tricks strotzt vor tatendrang im
neuen zuhause trifft die letzte
vorbereitungen
sie hat ihr eigenes bed and breakfast
eröffnet
in der schweiz hat tricks schuhe
verkauft auf kreta sorgt sie dafür dass
für ihre zahlenden besucher alles passt
[Musik]
für mich ist wichtig ist bis heute
machen musik die schweizer waren gegen
nach impfstoffen und nachher schlägen
aufgaben und was für mich schlimm schien
ich sie wenn du dieses konto muss immer
geflogen
und jetzt noch gesellschaftlich
unregelmäßigkeiten und der muss nicht
immer geflogen
das studio ist bereits gleich muss
tricks los zum flughafen ihre gäste
landen in zwei stunden
[Musik]
das heimweh war zu groß nicole gerstner
und sohn dörfer sind für zwei wochen in
thun zu besuch
sie wollen heimat luft schnuppern
verwandte und freunde treffen und nicole
möchte sich in der schweiz über
ausbildungsmöglichkeiten für sohn george
informieren mit seinen 15 jahren steht
die berufswahl an der uferböschung ja
das gibt es natürlich nicht
du bist einfach highschool koalition ahl
studieren und studieren zweiten
spielabschnitt machte eine rolle der
wirklich lieber zurückgeht schweiz gaben
die vorgänge um wieder zurück zu suchen
nach dem frühstück geht es los zur
berufs informations zentrum
[Musik]
den termin bei berufsberaterin bettina
winkler hat nikon von costa rica aus
organisiert er sprach sich aber für eine
lehre in der schweiz sind der deutsch
und französisch gefragt wenn joshua pech
hat küster die abschlussklassen der
schweiz wiederholen
[Musik]
in costa rica rund 9000 kilometer
entfernt beginnt für nike der arbeitstag
sein projekt für heute bäume fällen
ein knochenjob bei über 30 grad im
schatten
die bäume verdecken den pool von einem
der beiden neuen häuser die auf ihrem
grundstück gebaut werden
doch als erstes muss die stromversorgung
weg diese gelassenheit hat mike erst
lernen müssen was die zukunft von sohn
joshua angeht ist er jedoch nicht so
entspannt
einen vorteil hat dass er es begrüßen
wenn sie das machen dass ich vier jahre
und dann steht am tag der woche unter
wasser
klara monat mit der mehrsprachigkeit und
letzten tagen beschlossen um acht
respektive zukunft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sohn jacqueline ist zurück vom dorfladen
er hat das ziemlich besorgt
gut schweizerische tugenden und
lateinamerikanische lebensfreude für
seine kinder wünscht sich mike das beste
aus zwei welten
[Musik]
an der ostküste beginnt der frühling
nach zwei monaten in der schweiz ist
schön für einige tage bei seiner familie
ein weiteres mal nur zu besuch das
landes bringen ihre kinder zusammen zur
schule wenn sie da ist kostet die
familie jede sekunde gemeinsam aus
[Musik]
im gegensatz zu ihrem vater sind die
kinder längst in australien angekommen
mirja geht bereits in die highschool
jelena jannis und julian und die steine
schule
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zurück im ferienhaus machen sich schüler
und miriam an die arbeit
sie nutzen die kinderfreie zeit und
prüfen angebote für verschiedene resort
in steinhude qualitativ extrem im
gegensatz zur freude krieg ist diese
anlage viel kleiner
das eigentlich ohne personal händler
oder strom steht mit neun bands und 100
mann der gerüchten dann rasch
vorstellung jetzt machen mit heldt ich
okay morgen wollen sie die liegenschaft
besichtigen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
marcel ist heute früh als sonst in der
bar
er möchte mehr leute auf diese
aufmerksam machen
[Musik]
das problem die touristen kommen nur in
der saison zwischen mai und oktober die
pacht für das lokal aber muss er auch im
winter bezahlen wenn die bar geschlossen
ist im moment alles zahlen also stellte
ich mir die frage und jetzt als sehr gut
gelaufen und wir besprechen also sein
bis der winkel oder mit dem mit dem hus
mit dem studio oben noch ein vermieter
darf natürlich winter hat bis 30
und wenn man jetzt dauernd wieder das
ungetüm wie sie franken machen die leute
schon ich würde ihm aber nicht millionär
werte von sklaven
ich halte die schablone und durch
streichs wir brauchen eine stelle die
eben ist diese hier ist nicht gut
vielleicht hier probieren wir es hier
drückt sie fest bastian war nico
assistiert das logo auf der treppe soll
ein blickfang sein und touristen
anlocken
das war zuviel schadet
das ist nicht gut vielleicht sollten wir
es mit einer spraydose probieren aber
dann wird das schwarz eine dose sprühte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
später
ja
[Musik]
wir machen da noch eins und vielleicht
hier
das soll auffallen
die konkurrenz sind nikolai ist groß
dann bis morgen
nicole ist wieder zu hause
nach zwei wochen in der alten heimat hat
sie der familienalltag wieder
[Musik]
sie holt betty ab dass italienische
mädchen ist eine schulfreundin von
tochter josselin
der neue bekanntenkreis der thuner ist
bunt gemischt
aber er besteht fast ausnahmslos aus
menschen die wie sie nach costa rica
ausgewandert sind
[Musik]
es ist ein wenig mit gekostet
zusammengebaut
das funktioniert erholt
aber schon der typische
[Musik]
die familie lebt in einer welt zu der
vor allem leute mit geld zutritt haben
[Musik]
tochter josie den akt mittlerweile
freundinnen gefunden aber es hat länger
gedauert als gedacht
anfangs konnte sie sich in costa rica
kaum verständigen
diese gelder die sorgen die mic und
nicole wegen ihrer kinder hatten haben
sich in luft aufgelöst
die beiden wirken zufrieden in der neuen
heimat
[Musik]
down under lassen sich schüler und
miriam viel zeit für den neuanfang
das ist
ein großer teil der umsatzbedingt
natürlich viel weniger druck
ein weiterer vorteil die liegenschaft
ist eine nummer kleiner
die ferienanlage befindet sich am rand
eines kleinen dorfes
hier treffen landoll sankoh martin einen
stammesältesten
[Applaus]
vier gästehäuser liegen gut versteckt
inmitten eines tropischen gartens
er sagt nicht das paradies mit den
aborigines vom stamm der homberger ist
million schon seit über 20 jahren eng
verbunden
anke martin sollte prüfen ob dies der
richtige ort für einen neuanfang sein
könnte
[Musik]
das land ist den aborigines heilig sie
begegnen allem geschaffenen mit tiefen
respekt ich setze mich mal hierhin und
höre was die steine sagen
die energie ist wirklich gut
das ist eine quelle
ich werde mich in sie hinein stellen das
wasser kommt hier aus der erde
das ist gut
die meinung von anderen ort in estland
als besonders wichtig ohne sein okay
werden sie auf keinen fall hier
herziehen
es ist sehr schön hier und das fühlt
sich gut an
es ist alles vorhanden wasser steine und
der feigenbaum eine gute mischung aller
schwingungen für onkel martin stehen die
energien
doch landes von sich momentan noch nicht
darauf festlegen
gegenwärtig prüfen sie in welcher form
sie ein solches finanzieren und
übernehmen könnten
ob als pächter eigentümer oder manager
[Musik]
tricks kommt zurück vom flughafen in
heraklion
sie hatte ihre ersten gäste aus der
schweiz abgeholt
perfekter service tricks ist in ihrem
element
gästezimmer vermietet tricks hat eine
erfüllende aufgabe gefunden und eine
zusätzliche einnahmequelle für ehemann
marcel beginnt die arbeit in der bar
guten abend meine damen und herren
willkommen im sap heute abend haben wir
live musik von janney einem der
bekanntesten alleinunterhalter auf kreta
vielleicht sogar ganz griechenland
[Musik]
die gäste kommen deshalb läuft immer
besser
während der hochsaison hat maße sogar
vier angestellte
[Musik]
die abendschicht übernimmt der chef
immer persönlich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie viele andere sein leben
[Musik]
8 uhr am nächsten morgen
tricks ist schon seit längerem auf den
beinen und bereitet das frühstück vor
die hirnmasse schläft noch
er ist erst um vier uhr aus der bahn
nach hause gekommen
new york/düsseldorf hoffe dass man ein
bisschen schaffen
und da ich mit dem microsoft-system die
orangen tricks und marcel haben ihren
platz im griechischen alltag gefunden
[Musik]
auch maike nicole kommen ihrem ziel
stück für stück näher
gleich zwei neue häuser entstehen auf
ihrem grundstück eines davon soll ihr
traumhaus werden für den bau haben die
auswanderer architekt gar die beauftragt
für mike und nicole drängt die zeit in
drei monaten muss die wähler fertig sein
die altes haus haben sie bereits an
touristen vermietet sie investieren viel
geld da muss jedes detail perfekt sein
bisher geht das bett zwei meter 22 - 40
das ist groß und schon das nächste
problem die dusche ist zu schmal
wir können die dusche bis hierhin machen
aber dann ist man das holz mit
kunststoff überziehen oder wir
verbreitern die mauer um 30 cm und setzt
den holzpfeiler hier über das wäre auch
eine möglichkeit
[Musik]
vorstand und auch im ausland so manches
lässt sich ganz unbürokratisch lösen
für die bewegung mit mit fantasie
ausstellungsmacher floss mike nikon
könnten es eigentlich ruhig angehen
und wieder einmal nehmen sie sich vor
endlich mehr costaricanische
gelassenheit zu leben
[Musik]
seit zwei jahren bruder wiederholen
bevor der erklärung ob das ist rot kreuz
man eigentlich
[Musik]
familienausflug ins naturreservat vater
will muss in zwei tagen schon wieder
zurück in die schweiz
[Musik]
leben und arbeiten zusammen mit den
aborigines mit dieser vision hat für
familie dann dort alles begonnen
volle zuversicht sind sie nach
australien ausgewandert mehr als zwei
jahre lang haben sie gekämpft nur müssen
joel und seine familie noch einmal von
vorne beginnen
baku
die jungs
aber knapp
hey
schön ist auch weiterhin nur zu besuch
hier
[Musik]
aber die familie hält an ihrem traum
fest natürlich ganz andere aber sowieso
eine komfortzone nicht weg sie natürlich
sehr gut ihre kompositionen einfach
möglich also was im lager und das auch
mal loslassen taxi sagt vietoris
tarifrunde welt ist groß und hat
wirklich tolle sache zu kommen
das neue leben in australien bleibt für
familie lang dort ein großes abenteuer
mit offenem ausgang
[Musik]
ein paar mal pro woche holt tricks ihren
maßen zum abendessen ab
[Musik]
ein lebender mehr in der wärme des
südens eine rock und blues war und seine
bmw marcel und tricks haben das gemacht
wovon viele träumen
sie haben den lauf des lebens nicht dem
schicksal überlassen sondern es mutig in
die eigenen hände genommen
also muss selber ins rollen bringen und
jetzt heim ist drehstart
[Musik]
mike nicole und die kinder sind
unterwegs zum strand zum ersten mal ist
auch marianna mit dabei joshuas neue
freundin
[Musik]
vor zwei jahren ist nike mit seiner
familie nach costa rica gezogen der
schritt scheint sich auch für sie
gelohnt zu haben
29 grad warmes wasser sommer das ganze
jahr hindurch und die freiheit tun und
lassen zu können was man möchte
die playa santa teresa ist für die
familie zum zweiten wohnzimmer geworden
[Musik]
manches hat sich das paar zu beginn
einfacher vorgestellt
aber sie bereue es nicht tun verlassen
zu haben
so ist die aussage stimmt der schweiz
ist es passiert
heute haben wir glück haben nicht
funktioniert
das alte leben hinter sich lassen neues
wagen
die pioniere die welt erobern so waren
dann jedes jahr viele schweizerinnen und
schweizer aus und suchen ihr glück in
der ferne und auch wir begleiten wieder
einige von ihnen
ich mich abmelde nach deutschland nur im
ausland findet der platz für seine vier
sibirischen tiger und für seinen traum
unmöglich alexandra tc und remo müller
wollen ihren eigenen tierpark bauen
langsam langsam fassen remus wildkatzen
vertrauen in ihr neues heim
doch die bauarbeiten sind kurz vor der
eröffnung noch immer nicht abgeschlossen
und dann fehlt noch ein heftiger sturm
über den park
[Musik]
die ostschweizer familie ruckstuhl
wandert nach kanada aus zum zweiten mal
der erste versuch scheiterte je tochter
josephine war schwer krank und die
familie musste die neue heimat erst
einmal wieder verlassen jetzt hat vater
markus wieder eine anstellung als
farmarbeiter und wert zum cowboy
kälbchen aufpäppeln gehört für die
familie schon bald zur routine
aber wie entwickelt sich die kleine
josephine in der neuen heimat
und auf und davon in den süden spaniens
auf einem pferdegestüt mit reitschule
wollen miriam thomann und ostsee
endlich ein selbstbestimmtes leben
führen doch auch im paradies muss man
geld verdienen kurs wird pferdehändler
[Musik]
und auch im paradies muss sich miriam
ihren platz erkämpfen
die neue staffel von auf und davon ab
dem 8 januar auf sf1 um 21 uhr
[Musik]
und bevor ich infos präsentiert wurde
der leyen für oliver längert oder
weniger lang weg sind